no that's pretty that's yeah pretty
awful and This Woman's I said she said
she got two children
and so yeah no go ahead going outside
she got two children the last one was
for a guy that she had a one night stand
with because it was her birthday right
and the guys walking around in the
background and I'm just saying like I
said if
I would go back to it if women like this
are raising the Next Generation we are
going to be raising a society of broken
people
so what do you suggest you do about a
woman like people like that how would
you how would you you know women need I
think personally feminism women's
Liberation has been a detriment to
society
I really do believe well there's so many
different types of feminism well with
this this aggressive type the first way
feminism I don't have a problem with as
a matter of fact
um this aggressive type feminism not
radical a radical I Don't Need No Man
men of trash
um I don't know I can do it all by
myself okay type feminism for me leads
to women like this thinking that they
can call up a show just have sex with a
man because she's an independent woman
right she's saying she's single she's
just had a penis inside her this morning
right and she's saying that she's single
and she's on the show but the thing is
there's no shame yeah
you can do whatever you want and
there'll be absolutely no ramifications
but that's not how life works right yeah
anyway yeah I mean it would be great if
that were the case I think we would all
love that but that's not reality Works
don't you think in a similar way that's
what men have been doing for the yeah
the problem is
wait can I could I hear it could I just
hear how in terms of what have men been
doing for a long time okay as in kind of
not been there but they've been allowed
to do and they've been in cutting it
might be encouraged today maybe we might
stay or just they had a safe space to do
it to kind of do what like do whatever
they want in that sense like if we talk
about like what we mentioned earlier
like side chicks that sort of thing it's
kind of like an accepted thing where
they have a lot less parameters around
what they're allowed to do sexually so
maybe a man's not calling into like a
dating show but he's definitely like you
know having sex with a woman and looking
for the next one
so the majority the majority of men
historically haven't been doing that
because most men don't even reproduce
really yeah like most men throughout
history didn't read pretty like eight
thousand so there's eight thousands
about the kids that you're more focused
on eight thousand eight thousand years
ago it was 17 women to one men that
reproduced so it's more about the kids
so no so women women would pick the guy
historically so they could have picked a
guy with worse jeans but like women
biologically you want to get the best
genes you can to pass on to your kid
so so going back to what you said yeah
you said men have been doing it the
problem with what this society and the
problem with the feminist movement is
that women think they can do the same
things that men can do and they can't
they cannot do the same things that men
can do they think they can and they
think they're good the consequences and
the ramifications are going to be the
same they're not going to be the same
and so women use this argument all the
time oh well if men can do it we can no
okay do it and then see what happens do
it and we see what happens if you've got
a child you know from one nightstand
baby because it was your birthday that
child's now got a girl with a mum who's
basically a hoe right do you know what I
mean it's just like women of this
generation need to understand and I'm
not saying
I think this whole feminist movement has
made women think that they can become
the worst type of men that have ever
existed in history so there have been
really bad men in history right and men
have done really bad things this
movement has made women think oh I can
do what those bad men can do those men
are they're [__] up do you know what I
mean like those are bad you don't need
to be like the bad guy right but and
they also don't appreciate the good man
I mean right I mean you realize the
majority of women didn't even want to
but want the right to vote because it
came with the you had to be drafted so
most if you pulled women from back then
they said I don't want that and that's
the thing women have been protected
throughout all of history I also don't
think everyone agrees with radical
feminism like that's a very like Niche
feminism well and like generally it's
not that not yet the general feminism is
about choice and that you have choice to
do things that always comes with a
consequence but for me radical is not my
vibe to me there's there's only one wave
of feminism like I disagree feminism has
always been about freedom without the
responsibility starting with the right
to vote it was the freedom of voting
without the responsibility of getting
drafted
I feel like you had something to say go
ahead no I'm just listening at the
moment
eventually maybe I don't think that was
necessarily like
the root of first wave feminism though I
think that like
yep sorry it was started it was started
oh sorry sorry
so yeah I think that like
you know like historically when we talk
about this concept of feminism we are
looking at it in western culture first
way of being attached to that like right
to vote but I think historically also
when we look at like
majority people of color are people from
like lower more like impoverished
classes we have these ideals around like
women who need to like be working people
who women who need to be providing all
of this other
um support systems for their Community
which I think is also feminism and was
also always there even within those like
first waves can I can I just read you
something that you you might not have
known so um feminism was started in 1848
in Seneca Falls New York the suffrages
had 200 men and 100 women
um in the 1800s to the 1920s they were
seen as terrorists planning
assassination it was seen as a
supremacism movement I did know that
yeah okay okay so you don't you don't
think even then it it would have been oh
yeah it was totally extremist then okay
okay so what what are you talking about
extremist now so that's what I thought
you were talking about when you're
saying the first wave of feminism yeah
well because I feel like I guess just in
like
theoretical discourse you have like
three waves and like into a fourth wave
which hasn't quite finished yet which is
what like I guess we're kind of talking
about now like the radical like fourth
wave that isn't done yet right we're
trying to like figure out what that
might be
um but I think like whatever that
radical fourth wave might be also isn't
what the majority of women
um are even like feeling or practicing
in their everyday lives I also think
that like I think it kind of has gone
the other way a little bit in the fact
that like if you want to be a housewife
it's looked down upon I think like the
value because like we live in a couple
of society
um you are valued by how much money you
make therefore I from I don't know if
this truths my opinion is my theory like
in the olden days suffragettes were
usually like middle-class women with
money they didn't have any
responsibilities like for example they
didn't have any value as in their money
weren't wasn't theirs and they probably
wanted ownership for it if you're
working class if you were like bottom of
the barrel like you were working anyway
you had to make money right so
suffragette was not for people with jobs
already it's for women who already
wanted money because they wanted to be
valued in society they weren't valued
the same as their husband for example
now I think today it's not valued
financially right it's never been valued
financially to be a mother especially
now back then you get married like
there's a lot of child support now like
you have to have a job and be a mother
being a mother is a full-time job and
you never sleep and I think like if
women were valued in the feminine like
typical female role then maybe like life
would be better because I would love to
be a housewife yeah it's just it feels
like it's not even a it's not even an
option anymore
economically like with the first guy
could you have been